it's it doesn't oh I hate this guy
I hate this guy hit this guy
hello everyone is Gerald from Geek
culture and I'm reviewing the smallest
OLED display that has come through our
doors today if you have been following
our Channel you know that I'm on the
hunt for the best OLED displays out
there in the market that can be used as
a monitor as far as it goes the LG C
Series displays contain used to win my
heart and it remains to be seen if Rog
is able to get some of that love with
the Rog Swift OLED pg-27 aqdm before we
move on let's talk specs the Rog Swift
OLED pg-27 aqdm is a 27 inch 1440p 240Hz
OLED monitor you might think that
getting a monitor with a resolution as
high as possible is always the solution
but in this case the 1440p hits the
sweet spot for a 27 inch monitor it's
excellent for any entire game and the
overall picture quality remains ideal
within 1 meter or about 3 feet in
viewing distance plus it has g-sync and
freesync compatibility and it tops off
at 1000 nits brightness having used the
screen in both a dark and brightly lit
room modern OLED attack has done well to
tackle many of the issues plaguing it in
the past and has little worry that this
monitor will not be able to perform in a
myriad of lighting conditions so as it
stands the Rog display pretty much
checks off all the boxes one needs from
a gaming Monitor and one that is OLED to
boot before we move on to Greater detail
geek culture is supported by Brands who
help us improve our content over time so
here's a word from today's sponsor if
you are looking for laptop that does it
all gaming streaming and content
creation then look no further than the
Rog surface M16 the first 16-inch laptop
with an anime Matrix LED array so you
can showcase your inner geek to the
World featuring a 16 by 10 aspect ratio
QHD Pantone validated Rog nebula display
this display not only looks great but
also offers unprecedented performance
thanks to its 240Hz refresh rate and 3
milliseconds response time with all that
power comes with full width heatsink
supported by Rog intelligent cooling
with tri-fan technology to keep the
laptop cool while intense gaming or
heavy workloads for more details check
out asus.com the tricky thing when it
comes to OLED monitors is that they
generally don't make many variants in
this size and roshi is one of the first
to do so this means that folks will now
be able to access the best display
Hardware possible if you have limited
test space for me it's looking a bit
small on my Omni desktop relative to
everything else but I've learned to make
do my hunch is that for anyone looking
to get this display they won't be just
getting one at a time but possibly at
least three as it provides much more
flexibility for a variety of desktop
configurations this helps overall as the
footprint of the monitor is amazing its
display is extremely thin and the only
part that sticks out will be the Rog
logo at the bottom which houses the
on-screen display controller this makes
it slightly trickier if one would like
to orientate their displays or stack
them on top of one another the back
panel that houses all the ports juts out
no more than traditional IPS displays
similar to traditional displays all the
parts are angled downwards and we have
one display port 1.4 two USB 3.2 ports
and two HDMI 2.0 ports sadly the HDMI
ports are minor downside especially if
you are console gamer and want to Future
proof your Hardware just a bit the
biggest highlight of the Rog Swift OLED
pg27 aqdm this is 240Hz refresh rate for
this smoother's gameplay and is one of
the highest in the market right now on
top of that is a total response time of
0.03 milliseconds but it's more likely
that the real world response times could
be higher than that given these specs
the best use of this monitor would be
primarily for PC gaming with console
gaming being more of a secondary
consideration hence if you're looking to
get this display for mostly pcus this is
where the monitor really shines not only
is this the brightest OLED monitor we
have on the market right now in addition
the viewing angles are great especially
without the matte screen we last saw on
the Rog
pg84uq it makes a wall of a difference
and the
pg27aqdm Really benefits from this
decision in the games that we are tested
from Diablo 2 what are we kidding I've
put in so many hours into playing Diablo
and is the best experience ever across a
multitude of classes playing hardcore
available 4 where each character death
is instant and permanent being able to
see through all the action is important
I've moved through the game across a
variety of classes and the role is by
far one of the fastest classes in the
game in terms of movement and really
benefits from the prowess of this
display as you weave through enemy packs
it's important to be able to dodge
danger and stay alive for such a squishy
character when it comes to HDR the pg-27
aqdm with the windows default HDR
setting comes across as harsh when seen
on the desktop especially for white
backgrounds as this is not really
optimal use for this display it really
only shines once you get in game as the
colors look rich and vibrant without
looking over tuned overall it would seem
that not all OLED displays are made
equal as the experience on the pg27 aqtm
is far superior to that of the Rog PG
for 38 uq using this monitor for General
productivity use the
pg-27aqdm has a great pixel density of
110 PPI working on text documents like
this grip here means that every
character is sharp and does not come
across as blurry in any way after all
there's more to the PC than just Gaming
use the real drawback to this screen is
ultimately its size while it might be
great for smaller desktops one would
reach this screen to be bigger and come
in a 4K option as it stands we will
content like Netflix and the like isn't
the best experience overall and you
would really want to get this monitor
purely for gaming and productivity use
hence this leads us to the final issue
of price the Rog pg27 aqtm is priced at
999 US dollars or Singapore
1459 which is definitely pricier than
many monitor options out there is it
worth it I'll say it with a additional
yes especially if you have a generous
budget it's not a monitor that one would
purely buy for Value but if gaming for
the best experience is a major priority
then the Rog
pg27aqdm is definitely a pick for anyone
seeing has the next jump from Rog would
possibly 2 its 48 inch cousin there
needs to be a middle ground for Rog to
safely Corner this OLED Market as it
stands I think the Rog
pg27aqdm is one of the best 27 inch OLED
options out there in the market right
now if you are looking to overhaul your
desktop with one or more monitors then
this display should be did at the top of
any list and that's it from me today
please leave any comments below if you
have any questions about this Monitor
and don't forget to like share and
subscribe to our Channel if this review
comes in useful also do check out more
videos right here
[Music]
thank you
foreign